I remember these rallies in 2016. it was
exciting drained the swamp I also
remember lock her up lock her up right
and then two weeks after the election oh
don't forget about it forget I ever said
that no no no one thing you'll get from
me if I tell you I'm going to do
something I'm not just saying that for
an election and there are promises I
could make that may help me marginally
politically that I don't know that I
could that I could necessarily follow
through on so I will not make that Ron
DeSantis is saying the problem with
Trump wasn't that he said lock up
Hillary remember
no evidence of crimes no indictment no
conviction but they oh we're for Law and
Order but you have no reason to lock up
Hillary desanta says the problem wasn't
that Trump said Locker up the problem
was that he stopped saying it and that
he didn't do it this guy is as dangerous
as Trump he's exposing it every single
day